as everything in las vegas comes back to
life the sahara las vegas is not only
returning
it's upgrading the property on the north
end of the strip announcing some major
changes tonight orco mana joining us
live from there with
all of the exciting details zorko
well brian and denise says sahara las
vegas has some exciting
projects in the works as part of its
massive renovation
that includes a new resort pool and new
restaurants all set to open
in just months the announcement tonight
made in classic
las vegas fashion
the magic is back at the sahara las
vegas it is
you know springtime in las vegas you
know both both literally
and metaphorically the iconic resort
announcing some
major upgrades as part of its 150
million dollar transformation plan which
started in 2019.
opening this summer the azillo ultra
pool will boast nearly 35 thousand
square feet of poolscape with giant led
walls wrapped around it
and it'll also feature music like this
also new
follow an italian restaurant which will
join restaurant row facing the strip
later this year
the idea behind everything is an
intimate experience
these new features coming online are
really going to help
define us you know in in a market that
is
that is crowded this comes as we see
more signs of recovery amid coven 19
especially on the north end of the strip
the encore tower is back to operating
seven days a week and resorts world is
on track to open this summer
locals passionate about the progress i
feel like this site is uplifting now
i feel like at some point it was really
low but now all this
new stuff coming out rizzo world and we
base our
city on hospitality and that
re-emergence is like
what we need right now sahara las vegas
ready to lead the charge
we're just a proof point of that a
demonstration that this is
soon to be a very vibrant part of
the las vegas experience
also at tonight's event was steve hill
ceo of the lvcva
he says another promising sign is the
return of conventions in las vegas
world of concrete is scheduled to take
place this june and we're expecting even
more announcements from the sahara las
vegas
in the coming weeks reporting live
tonight on the las vegas strip
orca mana 8 news now